in this video we're going to think about
how ions will arrange themselves when
they form solid crystals when they form
these lattice structures
so just in very broad brush terms let's
say that we have a bunch of this white
cation and we have a bunch of
this
green or this blue-green anions and
let's say there are a one-to-one ratio
how will they how will that look how
will the solid look if we were to take a
two-dimensional slice of it to imagine
that we can draw what we could call
particulate models we're just imagining
a two-dimensional slice of the solid and
we're just drawing these ions as
particles would it look something like
this
where maybe
the
positive ion is all on one side
and then
the negative ion is on the other side is
on the bottom if we were to take a slice
would something like this
make sense
or maybe it's random maybe you have a
positive there
and then you have
some negatives right over there and then
maybe you have a positive and a positive
and then a positive right over there and
then maybe you have some
negatives right over there
would would this be a reasonable
configuration as they form these ionic
bonds
well when we think about coulomb forces
we know that like charges repel each
other and unlike charges or opposite
charges attract each other
and so when these ionic solids form
they're unlikely to form in this way or
even in this way because they're going
to form in a way that maximizes the
attractive forces and minimizes the
repulsive the repelling forces and so
what would be an arrangement that does
that pause this video and think about it
well all the positive charges are going
to try to get as close as possible to
the negative charges and as far as
possible from other positive charges and
the same thing is going to be true of
negative charges they're going to try to
get as far away from other negative
charges as possible and as close to
other positive charges as possible so
the arrangement that you are likely to
see is going to look something more like
a checkerboard pattern so maybe a
positive there a positive there
a positive there a positive there and a
positive there these are all the same
ion i'm not drawing it perfectly they'd
be the same size and when you do these
two-dimensional representations these
particulate models it is important to
get the size right because we're going
to think about that in a second
and then
the negative charges would be in between
so notice in this in this configuration
every negative is surrounded by
positives and every positive is
surrounded by negatives so it's
maximizing the attractive forces and
it's minimizing the repulsive forces and
if you were to think about it in three
dimensions you would have a lattice
structure that looks something like that
and we've seen this in other videos
now another interesting thing to think
about is the size of the ions that form
that ionic solid let's say we wanted to
deal with
rubidium
bromide
rubidium bromide
what would this look like if i were to
draw it in a two-dimensional particulate
model like this and i wanted to make the
size roughly comparable to what we would
see between the rubidium and the bromide
pause this video and think about that
and i'll give you a little bit of a hint
it might be useful to look at this
periodic table of elements
all right if we were to separate this
out into its ions it is a rubidium
rubidium cation and a bromide
anion
now a rubidium cation it has lost an
electron so even though it still has 37
protons its electron configuration now
looks like that of krypton
now the bromide anion even though it
only has 35 protons it's going to gain
an electron to become a bromide anion
and it also has an electron
configuration of krypton so both of
these have the same number of electrons
but rubidium has two more protons than
bromide does and so the rubidium is
going to attract that outer shell of
electrons that fourth shell of electrons
more than the bromide nucleus is going
to and so the rubidium in this example
is going to be
smaller
than the bromide and so if i were to
draw
one of these diagrams it would look
something like this let me draw the
let me draw the bromide first so i have
a bromide anion i have another bromide
anion
another bromide anion maybe i have a
bromide anion right over here
bromide anion right over there let me do
a few more
let me come a little bit if i was doing
this with a computer i would make them
all the same size so these are our
bromide anions and then your rubidium
cations would be a bit smaller and so
our particulate model right over here
our would look might look something like
this we want to make it clear that the
cation is a bit smaller
than the anion it would arrange
it would likely arrange in a pattern
that looks like this and notice i'm
trying to make the sizes
roughly
roughly
roughly accurate to show that the cation
is indeed smaller than the anion
although it wouldn't be dramatically
smaller remember they have the same
number of electrons and they don't have
that dramatically different number of
protons so and this is just a very rough
drawing
if they're dramatically different you
might show that in the sizes on this
diagram